another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation no claiming to  be or to have ever been steve irwin how  dare you  steve irwin was an international  treasure and you will never ever  fill his sensible shoes dr bright no  matter how much you say crikey when  looking at scp-682  no matter how many times you call it a  mighty big croc no matter how much you  photoshop yourself into photos of  scp-682  or how many australians you possess you  will never be the crocodile hunter stop  trying to make it happen no one is going  to call you that and stop tricking  interns into buying autographed  memorabilia from you we all know it's a  forgery